i understand your anger
at those who haven't gotten vaccinated
that 25 can cause a lot of damage and
they are to whom
to the 25
it is not about actually achieving more
vaccines it's about shifting blame away
from joe biden being a failure of a
president
let's be real about this joe biden is a
failed president he's a failed president
he failed in afghanistan and he blames
everybody else
he has failed on the economy and he
blames everybody else and he has failed
uncovered and so he blames everybody
else and what this necessitates is joe
biden making policy moves that are
unlikely to result in any sort of
serious improvement for the american
people but are simply designed to shift
blame away from himself so just like the
americans stuck in afghanistan
eventually said the administration are
there because they want to be there
right it's their fault that they are
stuck there not our fault for running
the worst
design surrender in modern american
history
nope it's really not about that it's
about the americans stuck there it's
their fault in the same way joe biden's
failure to prevent
the the vaccine
the vaccine mandates and the mass
mandates from being promulgated in blue
areas and therefore shutting down the
economy his unwillingness to recognize
when we have reached the end of a
pandemic and it has now just become
endemic his failures there have now
necessitated that he take this extremely
harsh action that is unlikely to ever be
implemented because frankly no one is
going to comply
so we'll get into the policy of this in
just one second and why i say that this
thing is never going to be implemented
on a wide scale white is likely to be
struck down why it's almost
unenforceable even were it not to be
struck down but
last night joe biden made the most
authoritarian move that i have seen in
the last 10 15 20 years of american
politics i'm having a hard time picking
it exactly because we've seen
authoritarian moves before very often it
turns out democratic presidents have a
bad habit of saying i don't have the
power to do x and then five seconds
later they just do it so you remember
barack obama said over and over and over
i don't have the power to simply stop
enforcing immigration law and then you
just did it and you'll remember that joe
biden said i don't have the power to
issue an eviction moratorium via the
centers for disease control and then he
just did it
well you'll recall that this
administration has over and over and
over said they do not have the power to
issue any sort of a vaccine mandate here
is joe biden back in december of last
year saying he didn't agree with the
idea of a federal vaccine mandate this
is after the election
no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory but i
would do everything in my power just
like i don't think masks have to be made
mandatory nationwide i'll do everything
in my power as
a president united states to encourage
people to do the right thing and when
they do it demonstrate that it matters
okay so that was back in december and
then in july his own press secretary
john saki said don't worry there's not
gonna be a federal vaccine mandate we're
not even thinking about that liars liars
liars because again as soon as things
got bad it was time for joe biden to
shift blame and again that's what this
policy is really about his entire policy
here is about shifting blame from
himself and his failures of policy to
the unvaccinated so here is jen saki
back in july saying no vaccine mandate
perhaps the federal government should
step in and issue mandates and if not
are you putting the needs of
unvaccinated people ahead of the needs
of vaccinated people well i think the
question here one that's not the role of
the federal government
that is the role that institutions
private sector entities uh and others
may take that certainly is appropriate
that literally is not the role of the
federal government says gensake well
until yesterday at which point the biden
administration seeking to shift blame
away from afghanistan and focus away
from afghanistan and seeking to shift
blame away from the economic stagnation
shifted away from the administration
decided the people you really should
hate are your fellow americans those are
the people you should hate the
unvaccinated who live next door to you
those are the people you should hate and
this brings me back to a point that i've
made one million times at this point the
worried in america the people who are
deeply worried about covet at this point
are almost entirely the vaccinated which
is insane once you're vaccinated you
should not be worried about whether your
neighbor is unvaccinated it makes no
difference to you
if this notion that you should be
walking around in abject fear because
your neighbor is unvaccinated is totally
crazy it is unmoored from scientific
reality first of all the vaccinated are
capable of infecting other people second
of all once you're vaccinated your
chances of hospitalization or death are
extraordinarily low because again the
vaccines are incredibly effective you
want to make people hesitant about
vaccine keep telling them that even
after you're vaccinated the unvaccinated
might infect you and you might die it's
a completely mixed confused message
but again it is not about consistency it
is not about efficacy it is not about
actually achieving more vaccines right
all this is is about shifting blame away
from joe biden being a failure of
president the economic stagnation that
we are seeing is not in fact the result
of these delta variants the economic
stagnation that we are seeing is a pure
result of bad policy being made in blue
states and by the federal government
it's about the media scaring the living
hell out of people so they don't want to
go to stores it's about people in blue
states saying you can't go back to work
because even if you're vaccinated you
might get sick again
there is a reason i keep repeating this
because it's true there is a reason that
all of the best states in america in
terms of unemployment rate are red and
all of the worst states in america in
terms of unemployment rate are blue
there is a reason for that it is because
a huge swath of this country has been
completely
disconnected from the reality of the
science disconnected from the reality of
the statistics and so joe biden is now
saying you need to blame your neighbor
don't blame me for the lockdowns don't
blame me for the mandates blame your
neighbor it's their fault that i'm doing
this
or maybe it's your fault for doing it
maybe it's your fault for doing it you
can see the blame shifting in real time
it's ugly and it is un-american it's
un-american to say i have to take this
policy against you because your fellow
americans are doing something bad so now
i'm taking this policy and i'm doing it
against all of you
and you should hate your neighbor right
it's the full metal jacket style
governance right somebody in your
barracks didn't do the proper thing so
now all of you have to do push-ups and
later you can go over to that guy and
put some soap in a in a bed sheet you
can beat the living hell out of him
that is joe biden's style of governance
it is in fact un-american and it's
evidence that he is a failure
as both a
president and as a decent human being
with the kind of power that he's
attempting to wield
in one second we'll get to joe biden's
ridiculous and horrifying speech frankly
the stuff that he was saying yesterday
there is there a low for biden there is
no floor there really is not i thought
that the worst speech that i'd heard was
the speech that he gave like last week
upon the withdrawal from afghanistan
where he championed himself and pat
himself on the back while hundreds of
americans were still stuck behind enemy
lines fast forward one week and now he's
calling his fellow americans treating
them as is his subject they're not
citizens anymore they are just the
people that he gets to order around and
if they don't do what he says he will
force them to do what what he says
and it is dictatorial authoritarian
stuff it really is amazing
last night joe biden wanders out to the
microphone about five o'clock in the
afternoon because again he has to make
that early bird special over at denny's
and he proceeds to yell at you his
grandpa simpson yelling at the clouds
he's going to yell at you if you're
unvaccinated and you know he's going to
yell at you if you're vaccinated too
because the fact is if you were just mad
at your neighbor if you were more angry
at the person who lives next door to you
then that would fix the country
so he starts off by talking about how
frustrated he is with the people who are
still not vaccinated right again
this is a free country or it used to be
and i'm not angry at the people who
aren't vaccinated i'm not again i am
very pro-vaccine i've told everybody in
my office i think they ought to get the
vaccine many of them didn't listen that
is their business that doesn't make me
angry because i'm not a tyrant joe biden
is a tyrant so it makes him super angry
when people don't listen to him and the
people that it impact
are the people
who didn't listen to him
again this would be one thing if the
unvaccinated were actually posing a
danger to the people who are vaccinated
they are not but that mixed message was
completely elided here because again
this is not about anything other than
joe biden is a damned coward who wants
to shift the blame for his own failures
onto the backs of other americans so
here he is
many of us are frustrated with the
nearly 80 million americans who are
still not vaccinated
even though the vaccine is safe
effective and free okay how about the
americans who have natural immunity
there's studies after studies showing
that natural immunity is more durable
than vaccine immunity
and yet there are no
there are no provisions in joe biden's
proposed rule for people who have
antibodies for people who already have
natural immunity
none because this isn't about science
it's about yelling at people he
continues along these lines he just kept
hammering this over and over if you're
unvaccinated it's your fault i'm doing
this it's your fault that i'm hurting
everybody right so that
it's not my fault i'm hurting you it's
your fault that i'm hurting you here's
joe biden
the vast majority of americans are doing
the right thing
nearly three-quarters of the eligible
have gotten at least one shot
but one quarter has not gotten any
that's nearly 80 million americans not
vaccinated
and a country as large as ours that's 25
minority that 25 can cause a lot of
damage and they are to whom
to whom
to the 25
right he which joe biden freely admits
and this is how you know that he's a
dishonest lying sack
this is how you know it right because
when he says that they're causing a lot
of damage again the rule of
externalities right which is where
government very often comes into play is
i can wave my fist around until it hits
you in the face and that is the general
rule of externalities
what it but what joe biden is now saying
is that he gets to intervene if i wave
my fist around and it hits me in the
face
if you're unvaccinated you're not a
danger to the vaccinated you know who
knows this joe biden who said it last
night
i want to emphasize
that the vaccines provide very strong
protection
from severe illness from covet 19.
i know there's a lot of confusion and
misinformation
but the world's leading scientists
confirm
that if you are fully vaccinated your
risk of severe illness from covet 19 is
very low
in fact
based on available data from the summer
only one out of every 160 000 fully
vaccinated americans
was hospitalized for covet per day
so what the hell are you trying to yell
at people for i don't understand i'm
vaccinated again i do not give
you can ask the people in my office as
soon as i was two weeks out from my
final vaccination i came into the office
and people had been masking up right
that many of the people in the office
had been masking because i was concerned
about me getting it and transmitting my
parents or 65 wasn't particularly
worried about me getting sick but i was
worried about transmitting to my parents
and
then i came in and people said you know
do you want us to wear the mask i said
first of all like i never told you you
had to wear the mask but if you want to
take it off i really don't care now like
i really don't care because it doesn't
matter to me joe biden is saying it
shouldn't matter to you once you are
vaccinated you are safe
but you should still be angry at the
unvaccinated
right he just continues along these
lines it makes no sense here he is
saying another incoherent nonsensical
thing
for the vast majority of you who've
gotten vaccinated i understand your
anger
at those who haven't gotten vaccinated
i understand the anxiety about getting a
breakthrough case
but as the science makes clear
if you're fully vaccinated
you're highly protected from severe
illness even if you get covet 19.
in fact recent data indicates
there is only one confirmed positive
case per 5 000 fully vaccinated
americans per day
you're as safe as possible
and we're doing everything we can to
keep it that way keep it that way keep
you safe okay so
so this old man is telling you that
you're safe once you're vaccinated but
then he says this he says now you're not
safe so on the one hand you're safe
because you got vaccinated on the other
hand you're unsafe now let me ask why is
he saying you're unsafe the reason he's
saying you're unsafe is because he wants
the lockdowns he wants the mandates he
wants those things he can justify his
failed economic policies so he can
justify a turn away from your focus on
afghanistan and so that he can justify
you being angry not at him but it's
somebody else be mad at anybody just not
joe biden this is the biden doctrine in
a nutshell be angry at everybody except
for joe biden
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang